[Music]
imagine walking past the bustling
construction site instead of workers
with construction hats pouring cement
and tying rebar it's teeming with robots
hundreds of transport BOTS delivering
materials aerial drones hoisting beams
and autonomous BOTS stacking bricks it
might sound like science fiction but for
researchers involved in the emerging
field of the collective robotic
construction it's a real possibility and
perhaps a necessity the world's
population is on the rise and so is the
demand for housing especially in urban
areas 54% of people today live in urban
areas a number expected to jump to 66
percent by 2050 and meeting housing
demand has a human cost 20% of all
work-related injuries every year in the
US occur on construction sites
researchers believe that the coming
decades collective robotic construction
will be able to step in to meet the
increasing demand for housing while at
the same time keeping human workers out
of harm's way and as humanity expands
its reach out into the solar system
robotic construction could play a
critical part in building habitats for
humans in extraterrestrial environments
one big question in collective robotic
construction is how will the BOTS work
together will they behave more like
animals or people in nature collective
construction is used for building nests
dams even bridges termites construct and
maintain nests built entirely out of
their own feces
laced with pheromones one termite leaves
a pheromone in the wall when another
termite smells that special smell it
adds more walt and its own pheromone
trace this feedback loop encourages
higher and higher builds these robots
act much in the same way detecting each
other's work and building upon it but no
need for feces or pheromones and these
BOTS communicate with each other to
construct a model building determining
both their current status and the next
step in the construction sequence
these robots specialize in coordinating
in air and on land arms stay in place
while the drone weaves back and forth
onboard sensors let the arms and drones
communicate next steps and handoff the
fibers this robot is inspired by beavers
ability to repair their own dams it
makes decisions about changing its
environment all on its own
here it builds itself a ramp in a
simulated disaster zone full of rubble
the termite or beaver like builder BOTS
have a few built in instructions but no
central controller guiding them step by
step in the human world there's usually
a person in charge overseeing shipments
worker safety and schedules centralized
approaches to collective construction
are also being developed which would
rely on a central controller
orchestrating everything in real-time
issuing orders to worker BOTS and
planning all motion paths to avoid
collisions or a worked out plan issued
to the whole robotic team all at once
even on a nano scale sometimes there
needs to be a plant he's agile
self-assembling nanobots zipping back
and forth are all operated using a
central controller which supplies the
robots with exact instructions would you
use a robot to build a beer dam well it
might be good practice for the bots the
types of structures that robots will be
building in the future might look very
different from today's buildings just
like human architects and designers
plans designed to be robot built we'll
have to consider the building's function
and comfortable human occupancy but the
types of building techniques they can
access will differ and incorporate other
kinds of efficiencies computer
simulations like these are already being
used to determine the most efficient
ways to build structures with bots
these simulations can be used to issue
instructions to robots like these from
earlier which are able to carry climb
and stack panels to build a simple
structure the robot constructed
buildings of the future might not only
have unique forms and may also be made
of very different materials future
robotic construction crews could
fabricate buildings using locally
sourced materials mined or spun and then
build based on the parameters of the
available materials
of the land or the structures could
adapt continuously like in this example
a sunshade made of prefabricated panels
and aerial drones that changes shape
throughout the day these robotic lattice
structures of plants growing in between
the braids in the future with the help
of genetic engineering the leaves could
act as sensors to alert us to toxins in
our environment while the current
technology is definitely impressive
there's still a long way to go before
our cityscapes are bought filled there
are still significant strides to be made
in robot autonomy perception design
there's also the question of what level
of interaction will humans have with
robots an automated construction
environment and how humanity adapt to
the economic impact of thousands of
construction jobs lost a robot laborer
that being said Collective robotic
construction has the potential to change
the way humans approach building forever
advances in learning algorithms and
smart building materials could allow us
to tailor structures to their
environments minimizing local impact
take building a dam for example which
usually entails surveying the land a
massive excavation phase and then an
equally massive construction phase using
robots all of these steps can be done at
once worker BOTS could survey the site
excavate and pour concrete all
simultaneously leaving a minimal
environmental footprint at a much faster
pace and we can't forget about the final
frontier robots could be used to build
habitats in extraterrestrial
environments deployed years ahead of a
crewed mission to say Mars to construct
living quarters using the Martian soil
surrounding the landing site the
possibilities are limited only by our
own imaginations maybe the robots of the
future won't dream of just electric
sheep but concrete rebar as well
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]